the title is particularly the subtitle
manufacturer consent in a democratic
society is a bit paradoxical manufacture
of consent refers to indoctrination and
indoctrination is inconsistent with the
democratic society so you can't have
manufacture of consent in a democratic
society and there's in fact a standard
view on this matter which does make it
inconsistent the standard view is
expressed for example by Supreme Court
justice Powell when he speaks of what he
calls the societal purpose of the First
Amendment enabling the public to assert
meaningful control over the political
process that's very obvious idea the
idea is that a democracy functions to
the extent that people have free access
to I to information and opinion and of
course the opportunity to act on it well
that sounds obvious in fact perhaps
almost tautological but it's worth
bearing in mind that there is a contrary
view in fact a very well-represented
contrary view in fact the contrary view
is probably the dominant view among
people who actually have written and
thought about the nature of modern
democracy and this contrary view can be
traced right back to the origins of
modern democracy in the 17th century
English revolution as in the case of
most revolutions maybe virtually all
that was a multi-dimensional affair with
a civil war between the supporters of
the King and the supporters of
Parliament but then a big popular
movement was against all of them and
didn't want and was trying to and had a
very populist radical Democratic
character to it and was defeated the
Democrats were defeated within about 20
years by 1660 and you read their
pamphlets they were saying that we've
lost the only question now is who's
slaves the poor shall be
King or Parliament many revolutions have
the same consequence
maybe all so far till one yet to come in
the course of that struggle there was a
great deal of concern over the fact that
the general population was gaining the
opportunity and the even the idea of
becoming involved directly in shaping
their own affairs and that led to great
concerns John Locke wrote that day
laborers and tradesmen the spinsters and
dairymaids must be told what to believe
the greatest part cannot know and
therefore they must believe one of the
contemporary historians man named
Clement Walker wrote at the time that of
the deep concern of the liberal elements
we're talking about now over the fact
that these guys with their little
printing presses putting out pamphlets
and you know agitating in the army and
that sort of thing
we're beginning to reveal the mysteries
of government and he said if they do
that they will make people so curious
and arrogant that they will never find
humility enough to submit to a civil
rule that has to be stopped and the same
idea comes right up to the modern period
without running through American
Revolution you can find it and so on in
the modern period you find major
thinkers picking up the same themes for
example Reinhold Niebuhr who's a much
respected --marla stand political
thinker and very very influential and
among modern political leaders wrote
that rationality belongs to the cool
observers but because of the stupidity
of the average man he follows not reason
but faith and the naive faith of the
proletarian requires necessary illusion
and emotionally potent
oversimplifications which have to be
provided by myth makers to keep the
ordinary person on the right course
walter Lippmann who was the Dean of
American journalists
wrote about what he called the
manufacture of consent that's where that
phrase comes from and he said that the
manufacture of consent has become a
self-conscious art and a regular organ
of popular government in a revolution in
the practice of democracy and this he
thought was appropriate because the
common interests very largely elude
public opinion entirely and can be
managed only by a specialized class
whose personal interests reach beyond
the locality that would be neighbors
cool observers now that was right after
World War one and the timing is
important during World War one John
Dewey's circle of liberal intellectuals
were extremely impressed with in their
words and their perception with having
imposed their will upon a reluctant and
indifferent majority with the aid of
propaganda fabrications about hun
atrocities and jingoistic
oversimplifications the point was that
as usual the population was pacifistic
and didn't want to go to war as any
point in it in fact Woodrow Wilson won
the 1916 election on the slogan peace
without victory a mandate which he
predictably interpreted as meaning
victory without peace very quickly and
with the aid of the intellectuals they
felt at least maybe they were
exaggerating their own contribution that
they had whipped the population into a
war fever and American Historians also
joined enthusiastically in the cause
they formed the National Board for
historical service the founder of it
said that what was needed was what he
called historical engineering a method
to serve the state by explaining the
issues of the war so that we might
better win it the Wilson administration
established the first official
government propaganda agency in the
United States called the Creole
Commission Commission on Public
Information which was a straight
propaganda agency to try to turn this
reluctant and indifferent majority
into a willingness to fight the war and
succumb the jingoistic fanaticism that's
actually a predecessor of a much more
ambitious program developed during the
Reagan administration the Reagan's
office of Latin American public
diplomacy theoretically under the State
Department but actually apparently run
by the National Security Council that
was an illegal operation as the
Congressional General Accounting Office
later concluded in a study of it a legal
operation which had the intent of
intimidating critics and the controlling
debate and discussion over Central
America its goals as they put it were to
demonize the Sandinistas and of course
to build up support for the US client
states the u.s. terror states in the
region that was exposed during the
iran-contra hearings by one of the very
few journalists who actually did some
work on the hearings did some
journalistic work instead of just
repeating the handouts Alfonso HRD of
the Miami Herald exposed this and when
he exposed the exposure later came out a
lot more details and congressional
hearings when he exposed it he went to
high administration officials to ask
them to talk about it and they described
the these propaganda efforts as a
spectacular success one of them
described the efforts as the kind of
operation that you would carry out an
enemy territory it's a very evocative
phrase and it expresses the attitude of
the Reaganite political leaders and in
fact of state leaders generally towards
their own populations they're an enemy
it's the domestic enemy that you have to
control and marginalize and you want to
make sure that they don't become so
curious and arrogant that they won't
find humility enough to submit to a
civil rule the out of the creel
Commission but going back to World War 1
there were a number of consequences one
of the members of the creel Commission
was a man who went on to become the
leading figure and sort of patron saint
of the modern public relations industry
Edward Bernays
he later wrote about what he called the
engineering of consent which he said was
the essence of democracy it's a and the
public relations industry is devoted in
the words of its own to major industry
that which was devoted to controlling
what they call the public mind educating
the American people about the economic
facts of life to ensure a favorable
climate for business and a proper
understanding of the common interests
the public mind won AT&T executive
observed 80 years ago the public mind is
the only serious danger facing the
company and it's got to be controlled
Edward Bernays went on to carry out such
operations as demonizing the democratic
capitalist government of Guatemala
working for the United Fruit Company
when the United States was planning to
overthrow it as it did in 1954 turning
the country into a trial House which has
remained ever since there's also an
academic twist all of this in fact it's
a major theme in the academic social
sciences going back at least fifty years
or more one of the most prominent modern
American political scientists Harold
Lasswell who's a leading figure in
communications and such things he wrote
the article on propaganda in the
international encyclopedia of social
sciences which was published in 1933 and
in it he says that we should not succumb
the Democratic dogmatism about men being
the best judges of their own interests
they are not the best judges are the
elites us smart guys the cool observers
and we must therefore be ensured the
means to impose our will for the common
good of course this he said will require
a whole tech new technique of control
largely through propaganda because of
the ignorance and superstition of the
masses same theme all the way through
the basic problem is this the idea is
that if you have a society in which the
voice of the people is heard you got to
make sure that that voice says the right
thing in totalitarian societies it's not
a big problem
you got a club in your hand and if
people don't behave the right way you
hit them with a club or threaten them
with it so it doesn't really matter much
what they think what matters is what
they do and that you control by force
but as the capacity of the state to
control by force erodes it's necessary
to control what people think and in fact
I think you find much more sophisticated
concern for thought control precisely as
the society becomes more free I don't
think it's surprising that the
sophisticated discussion things like the
public relations industry and the
academic side of it and you know the
journalistic side and all this kinds of
things have been sampling I suspect if
one did a comparative study you'd find
that they develop primarily in
relatively free societies ours is a very
free society in the sense that the state
has by comparative standards very
limited resources to control by force
and I think it's undoubtedly in fact the
most sophisticated in the terms of in
the reliance on techniques of
indoctrination and control public
relations industry in particular is a
American creation